c'est confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs et
vous connaissez dorénavant le principe
de l'émission partir à la rencontre des
antillais guyanais qui se sont installés
à l'étranger
aujourd'hui direction israël ont pas
retrouvé à pam salue abraham ça fait
plaisir de te retrouver on est loin loin
de la martinique ça représente combien
d'heures de vol ou de kilomètres à peu
près des escales à paris alors comment
tu t'es retrouvé en livre elle raconte
nous ton histoire
pourquoi tu es partie de la martinique
je savais pas trop quoi faire les études
etc ça m'attirait pas trop à ce moment
là et je cherchais est ce qu'il y avait
d'autres à découvrir dans le monde
cherchait vraiment à découvrir et en
même temps en france
je me suis dit pourquoi pas y aller
parce que ça donne la dame et je suis à
l'aise c'est martiniquais on est allés
ensemble pour l'année aujourd'hui
j'annonce avec sanitaire et je fais
alors est-ce qu'on en israël on connaît
la martinique est ce qu'on sait déjà
vous c est ce qu on a une idée même
vague de la martinique
j'ai eu ce problème la paix avec les
israéliens aussi avec mes 3 mai en
particulier quand je suis alarmé la
plupart du temps quand on y voit la
méthode des français ce que j'ai à
l'action on sait forcément je dis non je
suis départ je suis français oui
effectivement je suis français j'ai les
papiers etc
mais avant tout je suis martiniquais
donc forcément les gens disent oui mais
c'est où la martinique c'est quoi alors
moi je dis c'est mireille géant dit
clairement
je suis décalé dit pas exactement lille
parce que endroit leur expliquer que
c'était un mais avec certaines personnes
et je trouve ça hyper important et c est
ce que tu veux tu as pu faire découvrir
ce que toi tu es jeune forcément aux
autres jeunes que tu rends compte la
musique caribéenne la musique
martiniquaise enfin les raisons que tout
ça il apprécie bien sûr les israéliens
c'est pas un peu trop dans leur délire
qu'est-ce qui est au niveau de la magie
mais je me suis fait un entourage à ces
métropolitains entre guillemets autour
de moi et c'est des gens que ça fait
quelques années qu'ils sont en israël
qui sont déjà bien payé et c'est mes
amis que j'ai depuis deux ans au pic
charles alexy alors fait découvrir tout
ce qui est la culture martiniquaise dans
les voitures aujourd'hui j'étends de
copains et de copines qui aimerait
tellement dense et au bout ou n'importe
quoi et qui rêvent de venir avertit les
prochaines groupe justement de france et
d'israël qui voudraient venir martinique
après ça c'est pas alors par mois un
petit peu d'israël les paysages c'est un
grand pays un beau pays de ce qu'on dit
de nous découvrir un petit peu ce qui
est très bien en y seraient c'est qu'on
retrouve est vraiment toute l'enceinte
de paysages qu'on passe du désert
jusqu'à la neige rebelles agissent et
après il allait j'ai vu des paysages
magnifiques des lacs magnifique black
jack est extraordinaire j'aime aussi
dans cette ville qui a eu peur parce que
cette fille là me fait beaucoup penser à
j'ai vécu en martinique cette chaîne je
suis proche de la mer c'est hyper
important pour moi de l'avoir c'est pas
une vieille non plus qui est créé un
agent n'a pas le budget nécessaire
séparation de l'aude
c'est vraiment très espacées et ça va
peut être compensée
parti donc dans mon corps ici pendant un
an à peu près avant de pouvoir revenir
en martinique en vacances ou
définitivement alors là je finis mon
service me perdre en donnant est un fait
qui agréent mois pendant ces mets et
étudiants seraient les commencer
maintenant me serais mais toujours en
gardant mes racines ma culture qui
hésitent encore pour moi et ça me suivra
jusqu'à la porte de ma vie et je le
transmets même à ma petite amie aussi
important comment et voilà quand je vois
que ça a des airs que les gens autour de
moi eder et on n'a qu'une envie c'est en
fait devenir tous ensemble avec ses
bientôt
bon bah écoute ce sera peut-être pour
2021 on espère en tout cas que d'ici là
tout sera rentré dans l'ordre et que ce
sera l'occasion pour toi de faire
découvrir la martinique
aucun tué visiblement très attaché on le
sent bien et y est de pouvoir faire
découvrir justement notre belle île nos
spécificités notre culture à d'autres
faire cela à l'étranger le coc u19 est
présent aussi en israël comme un peu
partout dans le monde comment vous en
sortez à ce niveau là ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de cas ou pas je suis pas
exactement sur les chiffres mais on est
même surpris on s'est déclaré au niveau
des mains on est entre 100 et 200 morts
depuis le début de l'épidémie selon
qu'on y voie de l'inspection c'est tout
le monde en confinement beaucoup de
réflexions aussi obligation de porter de
masque les grands aussi
moi même j'ai pas mal ces dernières ces
derniers jours ça commence un petit max
libéré et franchement ça a du bon
en tout cas on te souhaite plein de
bonnes choses abraham et de revenir en
pleine forme en vacances cette fois bien
évident
merci pour cette rencontre et puis de
nous avons fait un petit peu découvrir
ton univers et israël merci à bram et à
très très vite
voilà confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs est
maintenant terminée c'est un plaisir de
passer ce moment avec vous on se
retrouve très vite eu en martinique la
première pour une nouvelle rencontre une
nouvelle destination à très bientôt
[Musique]